bonjour monsieur merci d'être avec nos
beaux jours des communes vous êtes
également président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale est justement le
modem et vous êtes très minoritaire dans
le paysage politique vous souhaitez un
report des élections régionales qui sont
normalement prévues au mois de juin
pourquoi vous souhaitez ce rapport on
est minoritaire dans le paysage
politique partisan sans doute mais dans
le pays je pense qu'on est assez
largement majoritaires la question
d'ailleurs c'est pas vraiment de savoir
si on veut reporter ou non les élections
c'est de savoir si on peut organiser les
élections dans le respect de la santé
des français
donc vous vous dirigez vous dit comment
tu viens c'est pas possible nous on a
fait une chose assez démocratique je
crois que c'est on a demandé à nos mères
dans toutes les circonscriptions où il
ya des députés démocrates on a interrogé
les mères c'est presque 3000 mère et ils
ont assez spectaculairement répondu que
c'était difficile pourquoi parce qu'il
s'agit d'un double scrutin les
départementales et régionales avec des
contraintes sanitaires qui sont très
fortes le conseil scientifique je crois
a eu raison de poser des contraintes
pour protéger au maximum pour rassurer
les français à elle si possible mais les
ascenseurs soient tous vaccinés
peut-être de faire des bureaux de vote à
l'extérieur d'allonger la durée
d'ouverture des créneaux réservés pour
les publics les plus vulnérables
là c'est pas afrique lab vous savez moi
j'ai été maire pendant 17 ans et donc j
organisais beaucoup d'élections est une
ville de 8000 habitants donc une ville
où on avait quand même quelques moyens
pour s'organiser
mais quand il fallait trouver des
assesseurs on les trouvait dans les
derniers jours voire dans les dernières
heures on demande le matin pour le soir
savoir qu'il veut venir dépouillés or je
crois que ce serait une mesure tout à
fait salvatrice que de vacciner les
assesseurs et les dépouilles heures
éventuellement les candidats sauf que
pour ça faut qu'on les connaisse la
semaine prochaine et c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes
et puis comment on va faire aujourd'hui
on a cette chance d'avoir la campagne de
vaccination qui s'amplifie mais est ce
qu'on va mettre en concurrence les
assesseurs avec les enseignants
éventuellement les candidats avec les
policiers et les mandataires des
candidats avec les questionnements le la
réponse est vite trouvée en réalité pour
protéger la santé des français
il faut que la vaccination continue de
monter en puissance mais qu'on donne la
priorité plutôt que cette première ligne
qu'eux au candidat aux élections la
démocratie peut-être en première ligne
en tout cas c'est ce que dit
gérard larcher hier ai dit qu'on ne
confine pas la démocratie qu'on a pu
voter dans d'autres pays dans le reste
du monde alors qu'il y avait l'épidémie
et lui il menace si jamais il y avait un
report qui était votée dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel qu'est ce que vous
répondez à la fée vous les confiner la
démocratie non vous savez moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le pour le
président du sénat j'apprécie d'ailleurs
beaucoup gérard larcher mais une fois
que leur ai dit cela mais je pense que
dans la période que traverse notre pays
il faut que les uns et les autres on
sache garder notre calme
moi il était très calme à yaoundé quand
vous menacer de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel d'abord sur le fond
c'est important de le rappeler
constitutionnellement les conseillers
régionaux ont été élus en décembre 2015
ils le sont jusqu'en décembre 2021 donc
raccourcir leur mandat de trois mois ou
de six mois ont été s'imposer absolument
aucun problème constitutionnel donc il
ay la déserte pensée politique c'est ça
que vous entendrez gérard lafay on a
parfaitement compris que en france
aujourd'hui quand vous avez une carte et
l'air vous devez impérativement être
favorable à ce que les élections se
tiennent en juin sans doute parce qu'il
ait l'air pense qu'ils vont gagner les
élections avec nous on va les perdre
il faut faire attention à ce genre de
pronostic incertain on avait vu ça
d'ailleurs ya un an aux élections
municipales et l'eire qui était persuadé
de gagner les élections avaient été
perdus beaucoup de villes dont marseille
et bordeaux ce n'est pas un petit chien
est ce qu alors vous dites que l air et
même la gauche peuvent avoir des arrière
pensées politiques en voulant scrutin
maintenant parce que ça va être
favorable sortant mais vous en reportant
le scrutin est-ce que vous avez pas d
arrière-pensées politiques parce qu'on
sait que les élections régionales vont
être compliqués pour la majorité et que
le seront peut-être un peu mois en
octobre parce qu'on aura passé peut-être
la crise sanitaire ou serrer un tout
petit peu mieux mais moi je dis bien
malin qui peut dire qui ça avantagerait
de faire des élections en juin ou en
octobre donc la seule boussole
ça doit être la santé des français parce
que vous savez une élection c'est le
jour du scrutin
c'est les conditions dans lesquelles il
faut l'organiser mais c'est aussi la
campagne électorale comment on fait
campagne électorale moi j'ai entendu le
valérie pécresse nous expliquer qu'ils
allaient avoir une campagne zéro que
vides tout numérique le la france et
enfin parfaitement numérisés je pense
que c'est vraiment une idée très
francilienne alors que la campagne zéro
co vide si on peut pas voir les gens qui
ont peut pas 10
lutter avec eux pas faire campagne dans
les médias notamment les médias
régionaux je pense au réseau france 3
région qui est très important et qui
suit traditionnellement les campagnes et
orale mais si si on nous accompagner
mais à la fin que le contact physique
personnel humain dans une campagne
électorale c'est ça qui permet aux
candidats de mieux concevoir leur projet
et c'est ça qui mobilise est ce que ce
serait pas un confinement de la
démocratie comme gérard larcher semblez
le dire que d'avoir 15 ou 20 % de
participation
les français si on dessert enfin un peu
la contrainte sanitaire est ce qu'ils
vont pas avoir envie de faire autre
chose au mois de juin que de participer
à des réunions publiques de combien les
chorales vous avez dit qu'il y avait
d'autres pays qu'ils avaient organisé
des élections depuis quelques semaines
c'est vrai mais eux ils ont le vote par
correspondance vous l'aviez demandé
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs mois pour
nous avoue rire maintenant un an
depuis on ne les aurait aussi réponses
et les élections ne sont pas organisées
au mois de juin si c'est la décision
finalement qui est prise ça envoie le
signal que les restaurants les terrasses
elles vont pas rouvrir au mois de juin
que les musées vont pas également ouvrir
le mois de juin que la vie va pas
reprendre un peu plus normalement au
mois de juin mais si on fait pas les
élections c'est qu'on peut rien faire
d'autre des coups lui pas vous bah si
moi vous rappeler ce qui s'est passé il
ya un an
il ya un an on a fait un déconfinement
et c'est très progressif on se dit bien
que au 15 mai du jour au lendemain on va
pas tout d'un coup se remettent à se
faire des bisous les sur les terrasses
on aimerait tous reprendre une vie
normale mais ça va être très progressif
oui mais néanmoins j'ai l'impression que
même ce côté reprise progressif mais il
est mis en cause si on peut pas faire
d'élection au mois de juin parce que
vous nous dites que c'est dangereux
d'un point de vue sanitaire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre en france mais
on l'avait vu on l'avait vu lors des
élections municipales je vous rappelle
que quand on a fait le premier tour des
élections municipales il ya un an nous
n'étions pas confiné donc on était bons
parlez pas de déconfinement on n'était
même pas encore confiné et on a provoqué
des clusters et on a provoqué des
français malades
si nous réussissons cet objectif majeur
qui est qui est 30 millions de français
vaccinés le 15 juin
c'est même pas la moitié de la
population alors que au mois d'octobre
on pourra avoir la totalité de la
population
donc les choses sont simples lire
aujourd'hui est-ce que
on se met en condition de respecter la
santé des français pour ce faire on fait
monter en puissance la vaccination et on
prend pas le risque d'en attrister et on
rend pas de risque on les a et que les
présidents de région se rassurent ils
pourront parler l'élection
présidentielle à partir de novembre
je rappelle que il ya cinq ans la
primaire de la droite s'était achevée en
décembre 2016 la primaire de la gauche
en janvier 2017 je suis content que ça
avait beaucoup nui à la démocratie je
suis ils ont envie d'expédier les
affaires courantes mais les élections
locales où j'ai été longtemps élu local
ça n'est pas une affaire courante citant
une présidente de région qui va
s'exprimer à 8h30 sur notre antenne
valérie pécresse ya un sujet sur le
modem en ile de france parce que le
modem la majorité des élus modem sont
dans la majorité de la vie pécresse et
soutiennent valérie pécresse aux
élections régionales donc le modem en
ile de france
il est sur la liste de valérie pécresse
ou 10 sur les listes en mars donc vous
avez quelques élus du mouvement
démocrate qui avait travaillé pendant
six ans et que valérie pécresse 9
alors parfois un peu un peu difficile
parfois bien passé dire au fond ils
avaient pris l'habitude de travailler
avec elle et c'est très bien je pense
que elle elle a eu cette habileté il
n'est pas interdit d'être habile en
politique elle est habilitée de de
s'acheter à bon compte le soutien d'une
partie de la majorité présidentielle
aujourd'hui représente pas le mouvement
démocrate modem il soutient les listes
dans marche pas mais c'est en 1900 c'est
une évidence en ile-de-france de toute
façon que les journalistes et creysse
ils sont plus modernes ils n'ont ils
représentent pas le mouvement démocrate
est dur allez-vous laisser
tranquillement dans le parti vous les
excusiez pas du parti c il avait sans
doute un petit syndrome de stockholm
quand on a travaillé longtemps avec
quelqu'un mais moi je suis défavorable à
l'exclusion par principe parce que si
vous passez du statut d'otage à celui de
martyrs c'est presque une promotion
sociale donc vous fait quand même un
petit peu stable non parce que pour le
coup vous savez je ne sais pas le
traitement qui leur sera réservé sur la
liste de valérie pécresse
je sais en revanche une chose imaginons
qu'au deuxième tour il ya une alliance
entre valérie pécresse limites et la
majorité présidentielle je suis pas tout
à fait certain que ceux qui sont sur la
liste de valérie pécresse seront
prioritaires à l'élaboration des listes
merci beaucoup bonne journée à vous
merci à vous